marvel zombies has finally come to the
big screen
kind of
[Music]
warning spoilers ahead
dr strange and the multiverse of madness
pushes the master of the mystic arts
into some pretty dark places that's
quite something considering he's already
gone up against dormammu in the literal
dark dimension traveled across the
universe to die on a far away planet
versus thanos and broke open the fabric
of reality with devastating consequences
in spider-man no way home the sorcerer's
latest outing in the mcu takes him
across the multiverse as he attempts to
stop an unhinged wanda maximoff as she
carves a warpath across universes wanda
still grieving the loss of her imagined
family from wanda vision has been
corrupted by the terrifying magic of the
darkhold making her a threat to every
universe in order to stop her he has to
dabble in a little dark magic of his own
in the movie's climax he dreamwalks into
another reality by possessing the body
of his multiversal variant with the
twist
this body is a variant of himself who
died in the beginning of the film
yes he reanimates his own corpse to
become zombie strange
i don't even want to know
this dead dr strange is the one who
helps america chavez escaped the demon
in the opening scene and he ultimately
dies after being stabbed by the monster
thankfully his body lands on earth 616
which is why the main strange can
dreamwalk into his corpse from the
post-incursion universe when zombie
strange heads for mount wangador for the
final showdown he's set upon by the
souls of the damned who scream at him
for possessing a dead body this
desecrates the natural order of the
universe which is why these hellish
spirits have been sent to stop him the
film doesn't explain who sent the souls
if anyone but they clearly come from a
horrifying plane of reality that we
haven't seen in live action yet it's
entirely possible they come from some
version of hell
so start up those mephisto theory
engines whenever you're ready as the
scarlet witch rightfully points out
strange using the darkhold to dreamwalk
into his variant's corpse is also pretty
hypocritical because he chastises wanda
for using the dark hold herself it also
shows that the hero isn't afraid to
break the rules for the greater good no
matter the wider ramifications speaking
of consequences the film's ending
confirms that people who dabble in the
darkhold's magic sprout a third eye on
their forehead in the comics dr strange
sprouts a third eye whenever he uses the
eye of agamotto that hangs around his
neck and it lets him look into the souls
of those around him it'll be interesting
to see what powers it grants him on the
big screen
it's great to see sam raimi return to
the superhero genre he already proved
that he can handle big blockbuster
action alongside an emotional story back
in his early 2000's toby maguire-led
spider-man trilogy but the black magic
witches demons and zombies of doctor
strange two are appropriate subject
matter for the legendary director of the
evil dead franchise if you don't recall
that classic horror series follows ash
williams as he tries to survive hordes
of the undead called deadites and some
of the scarier moments in doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness look like
they're cut straight from that series
zombie strange completely personifies
raymie's approach to the film as a whole
he's creepy and gross with an exposed
jaw under his rotting flesh but he's got
a heroic purpose
the marvel film really pushes the pg-13
rating harder than any of the previous
films in the series with its jump scares
and grisly deaths and zombie strange is
an outright celebration of it all the
magical corpse also proves that
superhero movies can really soar when
they lean into specific genres and make
weird off-the-wall decisions and let's
face it seeing zombie strange fight the
scarlet witch with a cloak made out of
damned souls is so so metal one thing's
for sure marvel should definitely
convince raymie to come back for doctor
strange 3.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]